[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous effectivement
peut-être que certains d'entre vous me
connaissent sur Youtube alors l'exercice
du TEDx c'est une première pour moi de
mon côté je vais devoir avoir un rythme
un peu plus posé je vais pas pouvoir
faire
je vais devoir et bien du coup
finalement expliquer les choses de
manière un peu plus lente mais écoutez
c'est un exercice comme un autre mais
dans tous les cas pour ceux qui ne me
connaissent pas je suis quelqu'un qui
adore à chaque fois m'intéresser à toute
l'actualité technologique qui peut
arriver je fais énormément de veille que
ce soit de lire des articles que ce soit
de lire des blogs des médiums ou autres
j'adore me dire qu'on est à vivre
toujours dans un monde qui évolue
énormément avec des technologies qui
impactent notre monde énormément
la dernière révolution numérique grande
révolution numérique qu'on a pu vivre
sur ces dernières années et qu'on vit
encore aujourd'hui c'est l'arrivée
d'internet je pense que tout le monde
utilise Internet dans cette salle
pourtant internet ça n'a que 20 ans dans
le grand public le web 2.0 qu'on utilise
tous les jours le la première fois qu'on
a utilisé ce terme c'était en 2003 et il
a fallu attendre les années 2008 2010
pour que vraiment ça commence à se
démocratiser et que maintenant dans les
dernières années presque tout le monde à
la fibre en tout cas j'espère pour vous
sinon j'en suis fort désolé mais
aujourd'hui une technologie qui n'était
pas là il y a 20 ans est devenu
nécessaire pour tous on pourrait même
pas vivre 24 heures sans cette
technologie
et maintenant ce qu'il faut se demander
c'est que malgré toutes les technologies
qui arrivent qui arrivent que soit la
réalité virtuelle que ce soit la
blockchain que ce soit du coup même le
web 3.0 comment on l'appelle
qu'est-ce qui va être la prochaine
révolution numérique on peut parler des
des monnaies des crypto monnaie on
pourrait parler effectivement de la
blockchain des méta verts mais je pense
pas que ça soit tout ça tout ça ce ne
sont que des évolutions assez logiques
de ce qui existe déjà non pour moi la
prochaine révolution et qui va vraiment
impacter le monde de tous ainsi que le
travail de tous c'est cette page web
cette page Web que vous connaissez
peut-être qui ressemble un peu à une
page de recherche Google mais qui est
très différent dans son fonctionnement
on va parler aujourd'hui de chat GPT
pour dire active free train Transformers
malheureusement ça fait GPT en français
on est pas très gâté mais dans l'idée ce
sont des moteurs de recherche sur
booster des sortes de Google qui vont
fonctionner de manière beaucoup beaucoup
plus puissante
en général justement je parlais de
révolution numérique avec Internet et
surtout avec Google le fait de faire une
recherche sur Google et quelque chose
d'assez commun tout le monde sait faire
une recherche Google et tout le monde
fait des recherches Google de manière
quotidienne le truc c'est que jusque là
quand on fait des recherches du style la
machine ne fait que nous donner un
retour du résultat qu'on veut on va
demander une recette de cuisine on va
avoir une dizaine de sites qui vont
donner une recette de cuisine grâce au
moteur de recherche on cherche à
s'informer sur la photosynthèse très
bien il y aura énormément de ressources
mais les ressources seront accessibles
sur des sites tiers la plateforme entre
les deux tout ce qu'elle va faire c'est
nous donner l'information
la grande différence maintenant c'est
que nous commençons à arriver sur des
réseaux neuronales dans le sens où
maintenant les moteurs de recherche
entre guillemets vont récupérer toutes
les données et faire une synthèse de la
réponse je donnais l'exemple de la
photosynthèse quelqu'un peut demander
justement des informations plus précises
sur ce sujet mais de manière beaucoup
plus concise et bien c'est quelque chose
de possible quelque chose qui n'était
pas possible avant
toutes ces technologies là elles sont
même utilisées pour les courges je sais
pas si certains d'entre vous en
programmation par exemple c'est
énormément utilisé il y a moyen de
demander un bout de code directement et
le tout va être donné par le chef répété
quelle que soit le langage parce que la
bibliothèque est folle il faut se dire
qu'actuellement chaque GPT 3 c'est celui
qu'on utilise à 175 milliards de
critères différents qui peuvent être
utilisés c'est un quantifiable pour le
cerveau humain c'est impossible de se
rendre compte ce qu'est 175 milliards
et le truc c'est que justement tout ça
est extrêmement récent on peut en parler
d'intelligence artificielle depuis de
nombreuses années c'est souvent galvaudé
pour les téléphones c'est plus des
algorithmes mais des intelligences
artificielles comme celle-ci comme le
réseau neuronal cette là n'existe que
depuis six mois depuis le 30 novembre
2022 le 5 décembre 2022 il y avait déjà
un million d'utilisateurs d'un outil
pareil depuis janvier 2023 il y a plus
de 100 millions d'utilisateurs de
l'outil et ça ne fait que grandir tout
le monde est en train de s'y intéresser
même Google tremble et Microsoft a
investi 10 milliards de dollars dans
Open high la société qui fait ça
derrière pour justement prendre la place
de moteur de recherche de Google on en
est à ce stade là et c'est pour ça que
ça risque d'énormément impacter notre
monde parce que ça va être utilisé dans
absolument tous les domaines
là je venais des exemples mais par
exemple il y a d'autres usages que juste
des phrases classiques il y a des
intelligences artificielles qui existent
depuis bien plus longtemps on peut
parler de Dali qui existe depuis
2019-2020 où on peut demander avec une
simple phrase un rendu 3D d'un poisson
dans un bocal et toutes ces images
seront générées on n'est pas sur des
images qui sont faites directement qui
sont récupérés sur Google Images non non
ce sont des images qui ont été créées
spécifiquement pour cette recherche avec
toutes les possibilités avec tout ce qui
existe du coup dans son cerveau ces
informations tout ça a été créé à partir
de ces informations là
d'autres cas d'usage vous avez besoin
d'une voix pour faire un talk
typiquement ou même d'un visage tout ça
peut être fait directement et c'est le
fait de vraiment utiliser les réseaux
neuronales pour pouvoir remplacer
énormément de tâches et d'où le fait
qu'il y a énormément de métier vont
complètement changer à chaque fois on
dit que les premiers métiers qui vont
disparaître ça va être les métiers assez
exécutifs que ce soit au d'accueil que
ce soit les métiers en usine mais avec
ce qui se passe en ce moment avec la
révolution qu'on est en train de vivre
depuis juste six mois vraiment avec chat
j'ai pété ce sera pas les premiers
métiers qui vont disparaître les
premiers métiers qui vont disparaître ce
serait les métiers beaucoup plus
numériques les métiers beaucoup plus
créatifs comme on l'a vu typiquement on
peut faire quelque chose de créatif
directement avec sa GPT on peut
remplacer une voix le travail de
youtubeur pourrait être remplacé ça
existe déjà des youtubeurs complètement
numériques qui n'existent pas ou qui
n'ont même pas de voix et qui sont
complètement fait par de la synthèse
avec des textes qui parfois sont aussi
écrits par une intelligence artificielle
et par exemple pourquoi s'embêter encore
avoir un graphiste quand on peut juste
faire un dessin sur pence et à partir de
là d'avoir un dessin extrêmement
détaillé de ce qu'on cherche à avoir
c'est aussi la question qui peut se
poser du côté d'une entreprise
finalement on peut avoir des résultats
en quelques secondes on peut avoir un
article écrit en quelques secondes
plutôt que d'appeler un pigiste pour
pouvoir le faire ce qui va prendre
plusieurs minutes voire plusieurs heures
alors qu'il suffirait juste de demander
cette information d'avoir un article de
temps de signe et tout ça pour être
sorti par une intelligence artificielle
et des entreprises ont déjà compris
Netflix a commencé à travailler
typiquement avec des intelligence
artificielles là nous sommes sur un
animé sorti sur Netflix Japon le chien
et le garçon exactement et tous les
paysages de cet animé ont été faits
comme vous pouvez le voir par une
intelligence artificielle c'est
littéralement comme ça que c'est crédité
si ça n'avait pas été crédité tel quel
personne n'aurait su que c'est une
intelligence artificielle qui est
derrière on arrive à des niveaux où ce
n'est plus discernable entre ce qui est
fait par la machine et ce qui est fait
par l'homme
et au point que même des concours sont
gagnés par des intelligences
artificielles un cas qui s'est passé en
juillet 2022 ou justement un concours a
été gagné par mille journée une
intelligence qui permet de générer des
images ou un utilisateur a juste mis une
simple phrase la phrase du concours
c'est sorti avec cette œuvre d'art là et
il a gagné le concours devant tous les
artistes qui ont passé des heures voire
des jours des semaines tout ça était
balayé par quelque chose qui a pu être
dessiné en l'espace de quelques secondes
evidemment il y a beaucoup de de rage de
haine par rapport à tout ça parce qu'on
se rend compte à quel point ça va vite
imaginez dire en 2020 que des
intelligences artificielles allaient
complètement dépasser l'homme sur plein
de points c'est totalement inimaginable
et aujourd'hui ça va tellement vite
qu'il faut réussir à s'y habituer et
qu'il faudra s'y habituer
on peut même justement des oeuvres qui
peuvent être complètement modifiées des
anciennes œuvres où on va pouvoir
totalement les étendre là nous sommes
sur stable diffusion qui va permettre de
savoir tout ce qui se passe autour de
l'oeuvre et d'avoir toutes les
informations autour
il y a même des cas de tribunal qui vont
être plaidés par un avocat en
intelligence artificielle peut-être et
on se pose la question de pourquoi on ne
ferait pas de la justice grâce à ça
pourquoi laisser l'homme et l'émotionnel
alors qu'on pourrait laisser et bien du
coup des intelligences qui sont beaucoup
plus aptes qui ont beaucoup plus de
critères et qui ont absolument toutes
les ressources pour pouvoir juger ça de
manière impartiale il y a énormément de
questions qui se posent comme des
questions droits d'auteur avec l'oeuvre
qui avait avant comme des questions de
droit tout court il y a beaucoup de
choses beaucoup de zones d'ombre comme
finalement sur la révolution numérique
est à internet internet à 20 ans il y a
encore plein de points sur lesquels on
se pose encore des questions les
questions de cyber-harcèlement on se
pose des questions sur du droit d'auteur
quand quelque chose est posté à droite à
gauche et là en l'espace de 6 mois on
essaie de mettre du coup des limites sur
quelque chose qu'on n'a pas réussi à
mettre en 20 ans sur une autre
technologie
pour vous donner une idée actuellement
comme je vous disais chaque GPT 3 et
fonctionne avec 175 milliards de
critères comme je vous le disais c'est
très très difficile de se rendre compte
de ce que c'est 165 milliards et bah
hasard du calendrier aujourd'hui chaque
openia a annoncé le chat pT4 qui
fonctionne sur 100000 milliards de
critères pareil 100000 milliards de
critères ça veut rien dire c'est c'est
incompréhensible 100 milliards de
critères c'est ça par rapport à comment
ça fonctionnait jusque là on avait peur
d'une intelligence qui fonctionnait
littéralement 571 fois moins que celle
qui vient de sortir aujourd'hui pour
vous rendre compte à quel point il y a
énormément de dévolution possible et à
quel point justement plein de métiers
peuvent être changés en parler de métier
graphiste mais il existe des outils pour
faire de la comptabilité grâce à ça qui
vont pouvoir peut-être remplacer les
comptables on a vu au niveau des avocats
peut-être que ça va aussi complètement
remplacer peut-être que ce sera plus
intelligent peut-être que ça coûtera
moins cher il y a toutes ces questions
là qui vont se poser et pour vous donner
une idée à quel point il y a moyen de
faire encore plus de choses aujourd'hui
la nouvelle version permet même de
savoir si sur une image quelque chose
inhabituel se dire qu'un ordinateur peut
comprendre que quelque chose est bizarre
sur cette image alors qu'à la base un
ordinateur tout ce qu'il fait c'est mais
répondre de façon à ce qu'on lui enfin
la question à laquelle on lui pose et là
il y a vraiment cette question de
réflexion de l'ordinateur pour vous
donner un autre exemple avant un réseau
neurone neuronal du style ne pouvait pas
à comprendre une blague ne pouvait pas
comprendre qu'elle était et bien du coup
le point de la blague ce qui avait à
comprendre dans cette dernière
aujourd'hui et bien ce même réseau
neuronal avec le fait qu'il fonctionne
avec 600 fois plus de critères arrivent
à comprendre la subtilité d'une blague
encore une fois ça peut paraître
complètement bête mais ça veut dire
qu'on ne s'approche de quelque chose qui
se veut le plus humain possible le plus
humanoïde peut-être que avec toutes les
technologies là qui apparaissent
vraiment depuis six mois même si ça fait
deux ans que ça existe mais qui évolue
énormément avec l'arrivée d'openheim
on se dit que peut-être que l'Android
n'est pas si loin que ça il suffirait
même derrière de faire ça avec d'autres
outils et il y aurait moyen d'aller plus
loin et pourquoi finalement on en a peur
et bien parce que ça risque de changer
comme je disais tout ce qu'on voit au
niveau du travail mais même au niveau de
l'apprentissage aujourd'hui ça faisait
pété est capable d'être étudiant à
Stanford il arrive à passer tous les
tests de Stanford c'était pas le cas
avec l'ancienne version qui était tout
de même pas trop mal je sais pas
certains d'entre vous ont déjà rendu des
travaux grâce à cet outil je ne le dirai
pas à vos profs mais avec cette nouvelle
version il y a moyen d'arriver dans des
universités supérieures et d'avoir des
résultats bluffants des résultats qui
vont dépasser n'importe quel élève qui
apprend depuis des années et des années
qui fait énormément d'ailleurs d'écoles
en ont peur un peu comme beaucoup
d'écoles avaient peur d'Internet
Sciences Po interdit l'usage de chaque
GPT au point de pouvoir exclure des
étudiants si ils utilisaient cet outil
comme plein d'écoles interdisez internet
à l'époque où dans les années 2010-2015
où c'était encore assez nébuleux ou
plein de gens en avaient peur ou du coup
on nous apprenait même à faire de la
programmation sur papier pour éviter
d'utiliser les outils à droite à gauche
alors que finalement si vous développez
aujourd'hui vous le savez que vous
développez en cherchant sur Stack
Overflow mais pour autant c'est pour ça
que je pense que ces technologies là il
faut s'y intéresser le plus possible
parce qu'elles vont avoir un réel impact
et surtout pour pouvoir les embrasser et
pas les combattre c'est quelque chose
que beaucoup de gens ont fait avec
internet de vouloir combattre son
fonctionnement de vouloir combattre sa
popularisation et qui finalement sont
tombés pile-poil dans la fracture
numérique ce qui fait que beaucoup de
gens ont énormément de mal avec ces
outils et on en retard vraiment vraiment
important avec cette technologie là ça
sera la même chose si du coup beaucoup
de gens sont réfractaires à l'utiliser
c'est pour ça que actuellement c'est
plus les métiers plus numériques qui
vont être impactés mais à force à terme
ça sera tous les métiers qui vont être
touchés une fois que du coup on pourra
mais vraiment combiner toutes ces
technologies là
évidemment je pense que vous le savez il
y a énormément de dérive possible avec
ça je pense que vous pensez typiquement
à la dérive du Deep fake qui qui peut
vraiment donner aussi quelque chose je
pense que vous avez déjà vu quelques
vidéos d'ipfake comme celle-ci et ce
qu'il faut se dire c'est que cette vidéo
là elle a 4 ans elle a 4 ans et demander
énormément de ressources ici il faut un
acteur il faut que quelqu'un fasse à
synchronisation labiale il faut que
quelqu'un derrière fasse le rendu sur
des machines extrêmement puissantes et
finalement c'est pas quelque chose de
très facile à faire en tout cas c'était
pas encore quelque chose de très facile
à faire et pourtant plein de gens sont
fait avoir il y a eu énormément de cas
où on a pris des politiques très
importants pour leur faire dire tout et
n'importe quoi et cela pour arriver pour
n'importe qui une fois que ce serait
plus accessible pour vous donner encore
un exemple avec et bien du coup ce
fameux salgpt4
c'est que maintenant l'exemple qu'on a
vu juste avant en une demi-heure avec
salgpt 4 il est possible de prendre
quelques photos de Barack Obama et de le
mettre dans n'importe quelle situation
les deux photos qui sont en dessous et
bien du coup sont derrière des photos
qui sont utilisées et à partir de là on
va pouvoir le mettre dans n'importe
quelle situation je vous laisse imaginer
toutes les dérives possibles si vous
avez un compte Instagram quelqu'un prend
10 de vos photos et il peut faire
absolument ce qu'il veut de votre tête
de votre corps de tout ce que vous de
tout ce qu'il veut encore une fois des
questions de droit qui vont se poser des
questions de droit qui vont se poser
mais par contre de l'autre côté on va
pouvoir faire des choses incroyables je
vais donner l'exemple de duolingo qui a
présenté quelque chose aujourd'hui qui
permet d'avoir un outil pour justement
apprendre les langues directement grâce
à ce réseau neuronal ce qui va permettre
d'avoir vraiment un coaching
complètement personnalisé plutôt que
d'avoir des cours qui vont être par
rapport à tel ou tel que langue là on
aura vraiment quelque chose pour la
personne et qui sera vraiment
personnalisé faut vraiment voir tous ces
réseaux neuronales ces intelligences
artificielles comme des outils comme
internet est un outil internet peut être
un outil formidable pour s'enrichir
comme Internet peut être un outil
dévastateur pour scroller 19 heures sur
TikTok en fait c'est les deux facettes
d'un outil du style c'est pour ça qu'il
faut vraiment pas à chaque fois se dire
qui qui va falloir diaboliser ça dans le
sens où derrière on va vraiment avoir et
bien des cas d'usage dans tous les sens
et ça qu'on le veuille ou non donc si
vraiment ça vous intéresse de voir
comment tout cela va évoluer je vous
conseille d'accéder déjà à ces outils
car ils sont encore gratuits pour le
moment et cela risque d'être de moins en
moins le cas et aussi parce que plus
vous connaîtrez ces outils plus vous
vous rendrez compte que ce qui vient de
ces outils là et ce qui n'en vient pas
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure je vous
ai donné plein d'exemples mais en vous
disant ce qui venait ou ce qui ne l'est
pas et bien du coup tes intelligences
mais plein de gens les utilisent dans
des cas où on ne s'en rend même pas
compte et peut-être que finalement même
cette chanson sot EDX j'ai pu le faire
grâce à chat GPT j'ai pu lui demander
plein de trucs et derrière et bien
pouvoir faire toute cette présentation
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]